hey hey um first of all i have to tell
you
i love this reboot so much it's so funny
i was just telling my whole family about
it i'm like this is a really good reboot
how proud are you of this show i'm so
proud i'm so excited i cry
pretty much every day and just complete
gratitude
i i just feel so lucky i feel like it's
such a continuation
of our original and we just wanted to
stay authentic to the original and
that means the world coming from you so
thank you so much
yeah you've definitely stayed authentic
to the original you know it's wild to
think that it's been more than 30 years
since brewster is on tv i feel like a
teenager
we still look like a teenager you look
amazing um
why do you think now is the right time
to bring back punky brewster
i mean for me i i don't care from 88 and
people are still like calling me punky
because i love punky and punky
and i'm like i don't know where she ends
and i begin because we are the same in
so many ways
and um and i've always wanted to bring
back punky and it was just the way
that the universe aligned and the stars
aligned
to have it come you know to together
during this time it has been
truly a mystical magical
amazing experience and i totally believe
in manifesting so i'm just like
keep manifesting seasons please everyone
watch it so we can keep going
okay i will do that for you yeah thank
you
you know this show the original show
resonated with so many people
um and you were just saying too like you
don't know where one begins and you you
know you end
how much has punky stayed with you after
all these years
she has stayed with me forever and i
think something that's so incredible is
i really feel like
both punky and myself are really like
coming of age again and i think
i rediscovered so much of my punky power
and her coming back to life again
it's it's just it's been incredible you
know and it's like that question of like
life imitating art or art imitating life
i mean really i believe like i
have have rediscovered so much of that
inner spark that i think as
as we become adults right and we're so
focused on our families and our kids and
you know and and i just you know wanting
to make everyone happy and then
um rediscovering that that feeling of
like that artistry
and that creativity and and that you can
be an amazing
parent and you can also follow your
dreams and be creative and
all of those things has been so much my
rediscovery of like self
you know yeah oh i love it the inner
child
yeah um i just interviewed freddie
prince jr
he did not want to come back to acting
and you and your show brought him out of
retirement
i mean what's that like for you and
having him on set
he's so incredibly talented and did he
tell you the story about when we met
so wild the engagement and then you know
so i mean it was like it was like one of
these mystical
magical moments where because when
you're when you're playing
you know people that have been together
for so long and now you know you're not
and then you have
the kids and and it's like in that
moment it's like all of a sudden
we have history this is amazing you know
and it was just it was so
amazing and he's so incredibly talented
and it was such an honor and i was just
so humbled to work with him and
just heart full of gratitude he's so
incredibly talented and
amazing it's fun seeing him
really show off his his comedic chops
he's so funny sometimes
funny he's such a cool dad
he's such a cool dad and like the
chemistry that he had like it's just
amazing
um you know the original series was so
ahead of its time from the diverse
casting to storylines that really talked
about
important issues you know how important
was this reboot to continue that legacy
it was so important throughout the whole
process of
from from the very beginning for us to
really
stay true to to the original
and you know and and to really like
to really show the perspective of who
punky would you know grow into and what
would her family look like today
and i love that and i felt like these
kids could really be my kids you know
what i mean and yet i was so
grateful that their parents shared them
with me you know
and that cherry is still my best friend
because
from the time we were babies like we
were sisters we never
even thought about you know what i mean
anything other than like
we were sisters like it that was just
the that was how it was then and it's
how it is now and so it's been
incredibly important to us throughout
uh bringing the show to life the
characters
our directors our surroundings i mean
it's
it it's i'm so proud of
of it um what was it like for you
introducing your kids to punky brewster
the original series i mean
are they like can they understand how
young you were look at that wild yeah
and they they have like gone through
different stages of being very into
punky
and one of my favorite stories is that
my two okay so lyric when he was two
we watched the punky series like on
these long car rides
and literally i didn't think he was
paying any attention and then the
following weeks he kept calling me punky
everywhere we went and he'd be like
punky buy me a toy like let's go eat and
i was like
you have to stop because people are
gonna think that i'm like having i'm
like asking my son to call me punky
i'm like dude like what are you doing
anyway
so now there it's very fun though and
literally it i love the fact that
you know my four-year-old as we were
going through the cuts and stuff he
would be sitting there just completely
captivated
watching like the entire time and
the seven-year-old and the you know 12
year old and the 50. so it's been
amazing i mean i can only imagine i just
was talking to cherry but what was
that reunion like on set for both of you
i know you've maintained a friendship
since the original show but being on set
for the first time together what was
that like
it was so amazing the elevator doors
opened up
i burst into tears i cried like a baby
like i
literally was so happy and just
it's just such an amazing dynamic and
such an authentic
friendship and i love her so so so much
and i think pretty much every day we
would just burst into tears and
one of my favorite moments was it was
her birthday and we were standing
in the tree house i don't know if i'm
supposed to talk about the tree house
but we were standing
yeah in the tree house and
i said how are you babe and she goes i'm
standing
with my lifelong best friend in
the tree house like playing make-believe
still and we just both started crying
because it was like
oh this is like a dream come true for
both of us you know
well congratulations on the show i can't
wait to see more episodes
i love the kids in this show they're so
much aren't they
magical and amazing they're so funny
like they're great
love the show thank you so much that
means the world to me
you